welcome back are you doing random spurts
of excitement my intros are do not like
any other podcast intros because refresh
yeah no matter how professional we ever
could get our intros will always be that
anyways welcome back guys to the Jan
Jillian podcast we talked about the
Julian things amongst the other things
this week's episode is brought to you by
bull and branch luxurious luxurious
beautiful sheets in your bed without
giant department store overhead just for
a couple hundred bucks great sheets some
of the best in the entire world the best
I've ever slept on go to bull and branch
right now bull and branch calm and enter
products code Jenna Julian for 20% off
try for 30 days you don't like it give
it back full refund other sponsor this
week is me undies won't you write this
Valentine's Day ah get the gift
everyone's talking about get some me
undies for him for her for whoever go to
me undies dot-com slash Jenna Julian you
will get 20% off your order
and free shipping Thank You Mandy sticky
ball and branch thank you sponsors who
really appreciate the support much
appreciated
yeah how was the movies today Julian
went to the movies whose movies in Star
Wars today ok uh first of all no
spoilers uh you spoil everything
well I don't understand what compels
people in like comment sections to just
like put spoilers where you can't
prepare for them yeah that's shitty
that's [ __ ] shitty I don't know why
people do have that again I could sit
here wondering why the internet is the
way it is at least our corners of the
internet like that anyway I'm not gonna
spoil it but the Star Wars The Force
awakens was absolutely incredible I had
high hopes and it blew those high hopes
out of the water right it was amazing it
was made there was something about the
way they did it which felt new and
moved 2016 but also so so true to its
form and its you know tradition in a way
the style the fact that they had all the
original actors who they needed you know
it was then they didn't have fast a
single thing but at the same time it is
a brand new movie in this day and age so
they somehow merged those two ideas and
did it really really [ __ ] well and I
enjoyed myself very much though and Adam
driver so out of driver is kylo Ren for
those who know Adam driver he's from
girls
he's uh what's his name in girls but
Adam Adam yeah his name's Adam yeah
anyway he we loved him are the best
foods entertaining character on girls
not that that's competitive but I would
only watch girls to watch Adam and if
there's an episode skills that he's so
funny he's just got a very interesting
like persona on-screen and who is and so
he's kylo Ren so he's a mask on so he
walks out in the first scene you see him
and I'm like holy [ __ ] if even if I
wanted to I couldn't mistake that walk
for like another person he's got such a
distinctive presence yeah just the way
he stands the way he speaks his cadence
it's very I loved him in Star Wars was
it difficult to watch him and not think
of him well cuz every two seconds I was
like ready to laugh with it cuz he was
making his little atom face but then um
it was like no way did Star Wars not
supposed to laugh but you know not gonna
whip out a roll of toilet paper in JAMA
in his mouth really yeah yeah man I miss
him on the show now anyway it was a
great triumphant return for me to the
movie theaters because it's been a
couple months
also this sweater it's brand new sweater
and our good buddy Louie Cole gave it to
us he's with us he came over one time
you're hanging out with the Gina and
Jesse when they were in town yeah and he
came over to hang out so he saved our
address because I got a package earlier
today and it was dressed to jennamarbles
and I'm like who has my address yeah
that's you know concerning sometimes
when you get things at the house you're
like
shit's now get real and it was from
Louie just really sweet movie we really
appreciate that that was really nice of
you and your clothing lines really cool
dude really doctor stands for live the
adventure
that's his company's hers clothing lines
name that's his motto mom's really cool
did you have fun going to the movies
though Julie never gets to over the
movies I did I hate going to the movies
just as we had anticipated since it was
a matinee there was just old people
matinee and uh moves away the whole
theater to ourselves so beautiful old
people like his old people Oh ancient
ancient yeah yeah like relationshipgoals
like they're walking around their canes
at all Nan's and really why you don't
believe me that there was a lady your
penis all right uh I mean I like going
Louise Julian's always like hey you want
to go see this I'm like no it's not like
unless it's Harry Potter I see your
Harry Potter is my Star Wars yeah fair
but there's been plenty of other movies
really I really want to see that in the
theater and I'm like it can wait I just
I don't see the point anymore I've lost
the like I feel like Hollywood and the
entertainment industry have taken so
many of my dollars and wasted my time
with bad movies when you go to see them
in the theater and you leave
disappointed more often than you leave
like elated that I've just given up and
I'm like you know what it's not even
worth it to go all the way to the
theater buy tickets sit there without
anything else to do except stare at it
and watch it and have the experience
like unless it's I unless I know it's
gonna be a great experience I just
rather have it at my house you know I
know I like 85 percent agree with you
and you know this I think Star Wars is a
safe bet like that that's you know I
would go I just don't really feel like
it yeah I mean III almost all the way
agree with you in a sense that like I
grew up go to the movies and then I
slowly started to realize the
progression of like the the watering
down of content like there was a [ __ ]
everywhere you know bad movies that and
suddenly like 9 out of 10 movies you're
seeing weren't great but then one would
blow you away and so it does feel a
little bit like you know you're getting
you're getting kind of taking a ride the
other 15% of me is like I really just do
enjoy
every once in a while not a lot because
it is it is a task and it is kind of a
hassle sometimes but every once in a
while I do just enjoy no matter what I'm
looking at on screen just going to the
movies you know whether it's a stupid
rom-com or if it's like an Avengers
movie or Star Wars like I want to go to
the movies smell the popcorn have that
experience every once in while just
because in doses I really appreciate
that experience if you're going to see
Star Wars or something big and epic like
that I mean if it's not big enough I
guess I need my desk know I know but
like you know you really want to see it
I get that I get having the experience
and I still do I would say that some of
my favorite movies that I will watch and
I would go to a movie theater for is the
animated kids movies those are
incredibly you know they're amazing
first off I think that might have been
one of the last movies that I saw in a
theater which is embarrassing I don't
even want to say it what the UM beta
baymax
oh yeah big hero 6 hero 6 that is the
last movie we've seen in theaters is it
that was like a year ago I saw in a
movie theater he was last time here in
the theater de I realized that I never
look at one think yo 6 came out because
I saw yeah um I guess as it was in the
holiday season of 2014
yeah that was legitimately aside from
the Smosh movie I saw that in the
theater because I was there for the
premiere as I was in November 2014 over
a year ago what is I don't know though
can you think of a movie that I've seen
in the theater outside of that like more
recent that can't possibly be right
Shane's movie yeah I was less reasonable
what about um did we see what's the
Bradley Cooper when he's a raccoon
what's that movie I saw that in the
theater didn't I Oh
guardians of coxy yeah did we sit out in
the theater I definitely did something
maybe we saw together yeah we wouldn't
have seen it separately did you come
with me Marc no I think you saw it twice
ah there it is ok so that was what
recent when was that
let me look cuz that might have been the
last time guardians of the galaxy was
definitely more recent than big hero 6
everything else I'm like [ __ ] it but I
get like you know if it's Jurassic Park
or if it's bad you seriously
if it's something that you know the ayat
what's really that's so embarrassing I
didn't go to movies all of 2015
except for the Smosh premiere but that
wasn't even really [ __ ] on like I get
it when somebody's really into it like
if you want to go see in the theater I
get it but like I do not feel life of me
understand people that just love going
to the theater and this unless that's
like really their hobby it's a hobby I
know that's my TV that I don't get like
the people that just go to see movies to
see movies I'm like watching all [ __ ]
makes it's the same thing the hobby no
no no no I disagree I feel like there
are people that like it cuz they like it
I got a couple friends Lee what's the
difference between everything alone like
they like that like they love the whole
thing and they also love movies they are
obsessed with movies good I'm talking
about people that just can't come up
with a better thing to do on the weekend
and go see some [ __ ] movie some people
just really love theaters yeah going to
the movies okay so forgets their hobbies
does it let them do what they want but
it is absolutely that's the definition
of a hobby I'm choosing to do with their
time what makes them happy people that
just go see [ __ ] movies to see [ __ ]
movies are like the people that go hang
out at the mall just hanging out at the
mall like people buy you things like the
hate watching version of going to see a
movie like they're just sitting there to
do it they're not enjoying it they're
just yeah oh yes but people who go hang
out at the mall as annoying as it can be
it's a hobby they like going on the mall
I know but like what I'm trying to say
is that I used to do that like I used to
go see movies because it came out and
like oh we should go see that movie
looks okay like I'll go see it and then
I realize how [ __ ] stupid that is so
I stopped going to shitty moves so
you're saying like the in a tradition of
seeing a movie just because it's out in
theaters right stupid at this point at
this point cuz there's better [ __ ] yeah
yeah no let me just stream it right to
your TV yeah yeah but I mean it as a lot
of people do like living living it doing
things old-school like bringing it
brings people in the style that makes
them happy like I used to go you know
just say someone grew up watching the
movies and theaters and every Sunday for
the rest of their life they want to go
do that because it like reminds them
what I don't know you know I'm saying
like people like to do that and I
understand that
that's something I can grasp not that
I'm like that but I understand it yeah
of course you can understand it I just
think it's [ __ ] stupid at this point
like you can't get me out of the house
if I can stream it to my TV well I got a
way to a month or two for it I agree
sounds great I'm gonna simulate here and
[ __ ] wait for I agree in a sense that
in the comedian sense yeah you know
maximum or illogical sense but we're not
really talking about logic here you know
we're talking about like what a person
like chooses to do to entertain them so
to me it does have to do with logic this
is like why would you go all the way
there pay all the money to see the
[ __ ] movie if you don't know if it's
gonna be okay when you could just rent
it for whale it will buy the couch and
not leave you're happy well by that
reasoning
I think fishing is stupid you can just
go to store and buy a fish by that logic
it's the same logic you're going to
stand on a dock for two hours and wait
for one little bite when you can just go
to the store what kind of logic is that
it's the same exact thing all right
there enough hobby yeah it's a hobby
people want to be doing it it's
something they choose whatever yeah it's
like it it makes them happy in a way
that most people don't find that makes
Maddie I just [ __ ] hate going to the
movies man I don't I don't love it but
sometimes I really enjoy it you know
yeah I go to young like I couldn't have
gone I couldn't have gone 2015 I
couldn't got a whole year I you know I
didn't literally never crossed my mind
once like if Harry Potter was coming out
yes I remember last thing is not going
to know hmm
yeah no I I don't love it but I
definitely enjoy it one you do yeah I
don't like I just I don't like it I like
you know when you're doing it there's
lots of people in there like that's I
get why it's fun but I like laying on my
couch with my dogs I can make myself my
own food my own snack my own drink you
can pause it you can do whatever you
want you can be on your phone you can
talk you can laugh you can [ __ ]
whatever and nobody cares it's fun I
like that and you know do the same
popcorn though if it sucks never I don't
I don't even eat movie theater popcorn
anymore
water so [ __ ] it like there's nothing
there for me okay don't get off look at
all but like when Harry Potter came out
I was that person I'm gonna sit and wait
in that line for four [ __ ] hours so
my Nintendo so I can play it in line and
hang out and be I will sprint into the
theater yeah I get it when people really
want to see a movie yeah I don't get the
like I get that it's a hobby but I don't
get the mundane throwing your dollars to
go [ __ ] sit and movie theater and be
disappointed weekend after weekend after
weekend like at that point oh what's
your hobby doing for you aside from
making you frustrated
it would make Jenna frustrated whose
name makes that person immensely happy
okay that's fair fair enough you know
it's not something you have to
understand you just have to understand
that other people buy it
yeah if you're one of those people that
goes to the movies every weekend and
sees whatever is coming out because you
like it but you're not a film buff you
do it because it's like your tradition
yeah something you want to do please
write in the comments with your
explanation because I'm genuinely
curious because that it's hard for me to
understand because I'm like nah dude
let's go [ __ ] and play mini-golf or
something today [ __ ] it I don't blame
you for not understanding it because to
each his own you know like you don't
have to understand why a person gets
something out of something they choose
to do all the time just like someone may
not I just want to show people like that
still exist you think you owe know for
sure they do
I have friends I do you would go to the
movie
oh yeah well in like uhm you know high
school I had friends which isn't too
long ago in terms of like technology and
[ __ ] you can get on your phone and stuff
it's not nearly as crazy as now but my
friends in high school that regularly
had traditions where they go to the
movies all the time and and it wasn't
like you know three times a week and you
know [ __ ] like it was just like met once
twice three times a month they would
make sure they were going to a movie in
theatres because it's it was tradition
or something they they did regularly it
filled something in their heart to go do
that whether or not it was the easiest
way to see that movie or the cheapest or
the less Crowley's crowded or you know
I'm saying like yeah but I feel like we
went to the movies the same way but that
was only because your choices when
you're like in middle school or high
school
so weekend you have a curfew like you
you can't just go and like do whatever
as the teenager so your choices are go
to someone's house and hang out and
you're not allowed to have a [ __ ]
party go to the mall and hang out and do
nothing and have somebody pick you up
and drop you off or go to the movies so
obviously if it's you know nighttime
we're all gonna go to the [ __ ] movies
because the mall is closed and like you
can't really I don't want to hang out
with your [ __ ] parents all right no
you but I'm asking this question
logically because now as an adult since
I have other choices and going to the
movies isn't only like your weekend
option am I alone in that are there
other people that choose not to go to
the movies anymore because if I was in
high school or middle school now I'd be
like yo I'll still want to watch a movie
maybe but let's do what it's so exact
I'm gonna guess right now I would guess
you're in the vast majority because you
could go to like Blockbuster and rent it
but that was a whole thing you know and
then you press a button on your iPhone
that's all yeah and it was a fun that
that was a thing like you would go to
this movie store and pick out yeah I get
a snack is like a step below go in the
movie theaters exactly ah but now since
it's so easy to watch YouTube TV shows
jeez I'm wondering if you are like in
middle school or high school you know D
is not your choice or do you still go to
the movies just as much as they people
did in the past because I know for a
fact that the money in the box office
has been dropping significantly if it's
not like some big action franchise or
yeah for sure people are certainly going
to the movies less than they did before
because they don't have to you're
absolutely right absolutely right
another thing I would say is that it
might serve as you know in a way like
some sort of therapy for people like I
said the word nostalgia earlier I know
that sounds my family a lot no I know
that sounds kind of goofy but and it's
not it's not meant to be attack on
anyone it's honest it's honest this is
me like speaking honestly is like you
know some people wake up every weekend
and play 18 holes of golf or some people
paint or some people go on long walks or
hike whatever the [ __ ] it is everyone
has their own therapy that they do to
relieve stress or to you know express
themselves in a solitary way
with friends and I think I think going
to the movie theater can serve that for
certain people especially given that a
lot of people grew up going to the
movies with their parents that's not a
not that you know what I mean and that's
something holds a special place in their
you know in their hearts and their their
memories and you know if like you know
if I was that way and I really felt
strongly about that I could carve out to
Sunday's a month to go do it because it
really just fulfills that I'm not saying
I do or I'm not saying it's like logical
because I'm talking about logic here but
that's more of just like trying to
understand where a person is coming from
who directly yeah goes against what
you're saying yeah no I see what you're
saying I just don't I don't know how
after so many movies like say you are
that person after so many like cliche
predictable parable like not even good
yeah movies at what point do you you
wake up and you're like let's go do it
again like I don't [ __ ] get that like
nah dude I'm not coming back here unless
I know this is a good movie like I can't
stomach watching that many bad movies to
watch one mediocre movie the ratio is
tough now you're absolutely right in
terms of like the way content is and the
way movies are being made like the
strategies that movie studios have now
it's different I mean not that YouTube
content I feel like very much so that
YouTube content is the same way you
might say that yeah here's my argument
for that you might watch you know this
how I feel I think mine's a better
example yeah um because it's so
immediate you have to watch like 15
shitty vines before you find one that
makes you laugh yeah you have to [ __ ]
you have to watch it a lot of YouTube
videos where you will find one that
maybe that's a microwave madman it's
fine that yes exactly that's the
difference is that it doesn't cost you
fifteen twenty thirty dollars depending
if you're taking a date or whatever it's
completely [ __ ] free yeah it's a
micro commitment I'm more than willing
to consume some bad content to find some
good content because I don't have to
leave I don't have to move I can do
whatever I want and it cost me nothing I
can't stomach spending all that money on
bad movies just cuz it's my [ __ ]
hobby yeah at least if you're fishing
you know hey there are more expensive
hobby
in the [ __ ] ground for some worms
invest in one pole good boom you're done
hobby that's an economical hobby in my
opinion aren't meant to be economical
they're meant to be hobbies you know
people don't [ __ ] sidelines because
it's cheap and it's [ __ ] yachts
yeah it's not like as a hobbies is knots
it's not being a penny saver it's like
you're doing it because it fulfills
something inside of you golfers whatever
casual golfers um people who you know
compete in martial arts whatever it is
like gym membership nothing it's not
about saving money it was about saving
money you know everyone would sit at
home and and eat nothing basically and
yeah you know I can't create a hobby for
yourself that's expensive unless you
have the money to do so or you arrange
it in your life now I'm not saying I'm
not you're going play guitars hold on
let me say I'm not saying that anyone
can do any hobby okay cuz collecting
cars and yachts and [ __ ] boating and
and being a golfer that's those are
luxury things like having all that is
not something that everyone have but
going to the movies regularly whatever
regularly means to you is something that
I would say a majority people can carve
out in their budget to do as a hobby
when it comes to hobbies that's a more
manageable one I would say then a yacht
then most oh you know more expensive
hobbies hmm they're okay no yeah I would
just rather [ __ ] sit on my couch and
I move that's all well I have a question
though would you rather sit on your
couch and not move would you really go
to cry movie theater with popcorn you
Kenny
I don't want to smell that popcorn cuz
it does smell good but I don't want to
[ __ ] eat it I will have a sprite
though it's delicious surprised good
sprite so yes Brighton years man I did
you get any popcorn when you're at the
movie theater no why not I was kind of
Harlan I'm sorry I just drink tea you
have like two drinks like I mean they
were like triple shots or something I
don't know I don't know reported some
[ __ ] crazy
hi pardon
I honestly should have gotten more sleep
and I'm surprised I didn't because we
were laying on ball and branch sheets
lovely comfortable luxury sheets it
feels like you're swimming in the ocean
on a beautiful pillow cloud or a wave
just soothing your entire body all
through the night Poland branch luxury
sheets luxury bedding for just a few
hundred bucks like guys it is a way for
you to just up your sleep game and
lately the little sleep we get means
everything it means everything because
when you have some sleep no matter if
it's eight hours six hours five hours
wherever if you're getting good sleep
getting in that REM baby it may mean
something so when I like to call it REM
because everybody hurts I'm just going
to say um Simon ourian for exam I
because later in the day you start to
feel it and if you had good sleep you
feel it was absolutely not get a better
night's sleep
right now guys check it out at Boland
branch our sponsor this week Bo ll and
branch and uh you know give it a give it
a look they have betting they have
sheets they actually just sent us this
amazing throw it's really nice which uh
it's really it's an action but a throw
is also a blanket and we use it in
living room now and it's wonderful it's
really nice since the dogs love it it is
next level blanket for a thermal blanket
is we usually have like fleeces and
stuff so that one's really nice like you
can fold it and leave it on the chair
and it looks nice yeah yeah at our house
doesn't look like a frat house no it
doesn't the kitchen sometimes does
something but uh I don't know when you
guys really get that offer but if you
try it
three days later you don't like it you
get a full refund that's that's
something great you know you can give it
a shot go to boom and branch calm right
now and enter Jenna Julia net check out
get 20% off of your order so thank you
to Boleyn branch thank you pollinate
also guys don't be predictable this year
don't get a box of chocolates come on
you can do better than that
get the gift everyone's talking about is
the me on you're better than that you're
better than that your butt is better
than that your butt is better than that
me on these is made of micro modal
fabric which is twice as soft as cotton
you don't really understand what that
means if you put a pair on you're like
oh [ __ ] I thought can get it like
they're comfortable how me undies has a
whole list of designs that will make you
just want to get them all this February
the yeah this February months
limited-edition designs from the
legendary artist Keith Haring how the
retro design is designed by is inspired
by love making it the perfect wow I did
not know that thing that is really cool
very cool they always have these guest
designers come in none of their
underwear looks like any other underwear
on the market and none of it feels like
any of these various artists you know
that is Keith Haring is a cool [ __ ]
dude I've heard the name are yes that's
[ __ ] rad
very cool ah this your guys cool job me
undies cool job when Valentine's this
year winning go to meet undies comm
slash Jenna Julian get free shipping and
20% off of the order that's going to
make you the best boyfriend girlfriend
whatever you are to that person you
could be this year thank you to our
sponsor yeah thank you sponsors also or
before February 4th in the US to make
sure your pair arrives before
Valentine's Day good to know so you can
have it in time for that special night
and [ __ ] chocolates how sexy do you feel
after you eat chocolates mmm not sexy
sexy but you feel sexy and me at ease
mm-hmm it's like wearing no wonder what
better is often they're really soft oh
man me unease they're so hot right now
uh anyway
are you glad that you went to the movies
Savannah absolutely there's no part of
me that well well hold on I woke up and
I didn't want to move mm-hmm
but once I got into the theater and star
was playing I was like
hmm I'm happy I would have been more
happy if I wasn't home over it but yeah
it was good it was good we just like had
a little celebration we were streaming
on Twitch last night and we got really
excited because the stream was finally
like reality finally got in next-level
form and uh we had friends over and we
were doing the UH we were playing like a
party stream we're playing like jackbox
games on it but all four of us were
screaming together it's really it was
really fun um we had a totally different
topic that we were going to talk about
this podcast we did but then we came and
sat down and then naturally just [ __ ]
podcasters [ __ ] much about the movies
we're going to talk about uh basically
just like the what it's like for us
living together as two people who and
you know have significant dietary
restrictions yeah being a vegan by
choice and me being gluten-free by
necessity but in a sense we both take it
very seriously
and so it's similar yeah there are a lot
of comments whenever we post like what
we're eating or cooking like on which
has been a lot of my blog lately or on
my blog channel recently there are a lot
of questions people being like because
Julie needs a lot of meat a lot of eggs
um that kind of thing and I none of that
your celiac and I would say for the most
part I don't eat gluten unless I've been
eating a lot of bagels bagels because
the yeah and it's weird because when
when when we cooked together when we
cook like a joint meal
you never eat gluten and I rarely eat
animal fat so much you're saying like
the the only thing that I eat that's not
probably that is you know me eating
wheat really is when I'll just eat my
[ __ ] bagels but I easily buy a gluten
free bagel it would probably be better
so there's no we could share most of
your bagels have eggs so your
different yeah but it's interesting
because a lot of people ask me why I
don't go vegan because jen is vegan and
this and that and uh you know I I
actually Jenna and I were talking about
maybe me putting a day of the week as a
vegan day for me from now on but to
answer the question is it's very
difficult for me to go vegan because
well a lot of the the vegan alternatives
to foods the vegan patties the vegan
fake meat the vegan all this and that
the vegan bread that all has wheat knit
like almost all the vegan specific like
alternative foods I cannot eat as a
celiac so that's that is a big
disadvantage if I were to go vegan also
I I feel like I enjoy sushi too much I
enjoy chicken and eggs too much and
whatever it's just something I I enjoy
but um I would do the one day a week
that's something I would be interested
in trying out I'd make sure that you
were nice and fed but Julian's right
because I really appreciate as much as I
think people that try let's just say eat
a plant-based size if you try and eat a
plant-based diet you know you're trying
to get as many fruits and vegetables and
as you can but you do need you know
you've some beans some rice yeah herbs
some protein or you know other things to
round out you can't just be sitting
around eating apples all day there are
people that do it and they love their
life and go you but I can't do that
freely freely does and freely like she
eats a lot of raw food and she's [ __ ]
great at it I think that's what we a lot
of people like wish or like to have this
romantic idea of like I just eat so many
fruits and vegetables but then you know
after your like 10th banana you're kind
of like you know what I could kind of go
for something hot right now - but I mean
as long as you're aspiring to take in
fruits and vegetables I think everybody
is in that same mindset as like I'd like
to be healthier you know sure maybe you
eat meat other products but everyone
would like to be a little bit healthier
we know that has something to do with
eating more produce unless checks medics
or some chili but in the reality of day
to day eating as a vegan this is why
appreciate youtubers like hot for food
Lauren Toyota I [ __ ] love her because
she'll do those what I ate in a day
vegan she's vegan and it'll be like I
woke up at this time man I just we had
some [ __ ] coffee here's some [ __ ]
that I had in my fridge I don't really
know what to eat right now and she
doesn't have it like this big planned
out like me that is real it's so [ __ ]
real and I appreciate it and um at first
I was sort of like there's a there's
some time she has like the prepackaged
the chicken fingers or something and at
first I was like oh you know I already
have those and how to make that yeah
cause you can toss them in some sauce
yeah John I would try and look for
something else but that I like really
came to appreciate the fact but that is
so realistic that as vegan you do
sometimes rely on those like packaged
things or even like veggie grill or
these restaurants that serve you vegan
things yeah like you know you don't want
to be eating [ __ ] tofu all the time
or like a process fake chicken or
whatever but like sometimes you do
because it's fast and easy and you're
just like everybody else like sometimes
you're in a rush and you just need to
eat something Nick you know am I gonna
eat some [ __ ] tofu cream cheese how
the [ __ ] yeah I am you know everything
is not just all apples all the time
oranges and you know fresh produce like
thick my shit's bad right now I don't
have time to go to the grocery store
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna heat up this
thing right now I'm talking about apples
and bagels here realistic beautiful
things completely sick but you're so
right and when you say like it would be
slightly more challenging for you
sometimes it would take a lot more prep
for you than for me as a vegan because
you're also celiac yeah you know yeah
there's not a big crossover yeah there
would be but there's not yeah you know
like everything that might be really
easy to me because Julian I would say
when we go out to eat has a much more
difficult time finding things that he
can eat than I do because I don't
technically have food allergies aside
from like fish I'd said cuz which does
make me actually throw out I don't get
like hives that my throat doesn't close
not like
I literally just stood up um but Julian
is like allergic so it's very
essentially it's it's technically not an
allergy but yeah it's a it's a disease
the disease its condition you have an
aversion you know what I'm saying yeah
lately you need to ask like what's in
the sauce and things like that like
every little thing um because it's not
always straightforward like something
might seem straightforward to me because
I don't eat meat or animal products but
at least I'm not having to check in
those meat or animal products for the
sake of you're not like a nerd or a
flower or something like that that's
difficult thickener yeah yeah like there
will be something like black bean soup
and I can be like I'll just please don't
put any cheese on there and I know that
it's okay because you've already asked
yeah and then truly gonna leave it and
really will get very sick because they
[ __ ] threw a bunch of flour in there
that's literally happened before I know
it has you were there for that
yeah um no yeah I mean it's um there are
two different beasts but they're of you
know they're of the same species I would
say and you know like I get a lot of
comments which [ __ ] do you make me
happy like on vlogs and what not saying
I'm gluten-free now or I'm just
diagnosed with celiac recently what do i
do where do I go and you know my answer
I try to answer as much as I can but in
general you know there's found a celiac
disease foundation is amazing I've used
them since I first got diagnosed over
eight years ago but there's you know
there's ways to navigate now where you
are able to implement solutions in real
life yeah you know that means going out
and being social in the world not just
having to cook all your meals and little
tricks and knowledge everything like
that you know and there's great
communities out there but you know I
would say if I were dating someone who
just had zero care what they ate you
know they ate anything and everything it
would be difficult it would be a lot
more difficult than someone who
understands and recognizes what it's
like to form a diet because of something
other than you know I want to lose five
pounds you know like a real like
purposeful diet that has that has
benefits that you see in value
so yeah I mean would you agree that like
the fact that I have to eat a certain
way helps because just because I'm you
know helps you know hundred percent I've
had this conversation with a few people
recently is that as Americans you know
depending maybe at what your religion is
but as Americans in our culture nothing
is really off limits to us you know we
have no cultural boundaries in terms of
what we should and shouldn't eat you
know Judaism so there's a lot of people
to keep kosher or even in Catholicism
Christianity what is that thing you
don't eat like meat on Fridays or
whatever I don't [ __ ] I can't
remember the point of it is is that
there's no council isn't as Americans so
unless you have a specific religion
teaching you otherwise we are not taught
like any boundaries in terms of our diet
which is why I think we're all kind of
like no no no no no you know what I mean
they have no no qualms with just eating
anything and everything so it does it
has helped me as an adult to realize
that about myself is that you know maybe
set boundaries according to what you
like or don't like or believe in or you
think is right and it's been very
helpful dating someone with a different
dietary restriction yeah to help you
understand it hey I can't eat this
because my body physically rejects it
but you can do the same thing because
it's really not that difficult you're
kind of on the same team yeah yeah no I
agree completely I think I think it's
kind of a blessing in disguise that we
both might have different things but in
terms of having very different diets I
think um what people really want to know
the most is you know a does it create
any problems or be how do you do it
smoothly without any bumps in the road
and I would say the the biggest answer
to that is genuinely respecting what the
other person eats yeah and like helping
them and supporting them do that because
if you know you're paleo or your
low-carb or your [ __ ] whatever it is
is if you have nobody around you that
understands or supports you it's really
ice movable it's in small because food
is such a unit you and I have both been
in that yeah it's a big part of our
lives and you know this past
Thanksgiving and through the holiday
season even in Japan it was it was hard
for me because I've always been on and
off since like 2009-2010 with being a
vegan and I would always fall back into
this like not gonna I'm not gonna put my
needs and wants ahead of everyone else's
so I'm just going to shut my mouth and
deal with it and I finally felt like I
have support from my family and from you
and from friends that are like dude
that's what you eat that's totally fine
you know what I mean
and I felt okay being like I can't I'm
not just gonna eat whatever because I
don't want to open my mouth you know and
finally it was like nah dude this is
what I eat and that's like being a
celiac is at least Julianne has this
like concrete thing to be like I
physically can't [ __ ] eat it so that
was when I was becoming a vegan it was
hard for me in the beginning to say I
don't eat that because I don't have a
concrete reason why I do now yeah you do
at the time it was like I just don't
want to like Kimmy please understand
that and people were just [ __ ] rip on
me especially as I lived in Boston and I
feel like it just at the time had zero
tolerance for it and they're like [ __ ]
you Jenna that's the same thing it's the
same thing people you know when people
are foreign to it it's the most
isolating feeling ever right you know do
you think I know the first the first
response anyway we're always gives me
one I'm like oh I can't eat that or I'm
naughty I'm can't eat gluten oh your
channel you're going low carb cool you
know I mean like they just assume it's
like a fad or a diet or whatever it's
never treated seriously but you know
it's a I'm actually a very proud of you
and you know I'm proud of you in terms
of how how well you've been doing the
vegan this time around but I'm also
proud that you finally just you were
like you know what [ __ ] it I'm putting
myself in the forefront and saying maybe
a couple times it's going to be annoying
and I might have to be an inconvenience
but I'm doing this for me because this
is a you know
ultimately all of my life right it's the
only way that my body really feels right
honestly but um I was gonna say
something I know I [ __ ] forgot damn
it [ __ ] in chronic vegan shut up
no um in terms of us eating together uh
what's been really helpful is yes both
of us need to be open and vocal about
what we need and want but also like if
Julian is as a vegan obviously I don't
want to consume any animal products and
I don't consume any animal products but
that doesn't mean I've got to stand in
the kitchen and cry human tears when
Julian is cooking his meat like because
Julian eats so much [ __ ] meat and
what's important is that like you
understand and support the other
person's diet even if it's not something
that you would personally consume like
Julian needs to eat sushi or else he
will die according to Julian obviously
he would still stay alive but you know
in in your life in your mind right now
you need to eat sushi or else you're
gonna die unless you were given another
reason not to it's very good point and I
you give Julian a lecture about why I
think he shouldn't eat that no like
that's for Julian to figure out in
Julian too if if you ever want to not
but other than that you have to let
somebody do what feels right for their
body 100% 100% like if I want to eat a
[ __ ] bagel made out of pure gluten
I'm gonna do it am I gonna rub it all
over Julian no no am I gonna am I going
to comment on it watch me eat it no of
course not but obviously there's shitty
people in both of our parties that have
you know given up bad images to both
parties like the vegans who shame people
for shame people for all sorts of [ __ ]
and then the gluten-free people who are
idiots is [ __ ] me you know right
ruining it for the people I gots who
just want to live normally be respectful
but also coexist right but I mean in
terms of coexisting I think whatever
your diet or anybody else's diet that
you live with as long as you support
each other like anything is possible in
terms of being able to co-exist because
when we're cooking together we both
usually just come up with a side that we
can both eat Jenni share the main dish
and we each come up with our own
well yes if ik know you really like your
chicken I'll eat like whatever but we
can share risotto with er and a
vegetable will always share together so
that means that we're not making it with
milk butter eggs cheese anything like
that and what Julian eats his meat he'll
eat is me when I something else likes
something else so it's a nice balance we
got but it just boils down to support
and caring there are people in my most
recent vlog that I'm like I'm a teenager
and I want to know if you think it's
possible for me to be gluten-free or be
vegan or be there and be a vegetarian
because in a lot of people's homes and
families they come from you know
traditional parents that cook you meat
potatoes and [ __ ] vegetables that's
what you [ __ ] eat that's your meal um
you know what do I do and the answer is
you unless you're feeding yourself and
paying things ganker things yourself you
do need support from people around you
yeah and even as an adult you need
support from people around you or else
it's just it's a really hard road by
yourself it's not easy
no but it's um yeah that's a good point
and once once you're able to find the
support whether it's from yourself or
other people are both that's when you
can successfully do it yeah but Julian's
not gonna make fun of me if I gluten and
I'm not gonna make funny if you eat
sushi I wouldn't even care if you did I
was just eating more sushi
she would be blacking out from eating
sushi so he wouldn't be able to hear me
but I will I'm going to get you to go
maybe one day a week I'm like and just
try it I like that I think I could do
that well I mean it's all a matter of
dinner yeah no true
and I was gonna I was gonna make a vlog
about it I'm still going to some day
yeah but even if you just decided maybe
one day because you love me and eggs and
stuff like that as much as anybody else
out there yeah if you just decided that
one day a week I'm going to do something
because I think you know I have a choice
I have a choice maybe not to eat an
animal product today so today is the day
I'm just not going to if you did that
for like one day week you know you could
make a significant impact oh yeah for
sure you know for sure and I think that
you'd feel good
the impact is great but it's also I
think more importantly is doing
something that makes your effect on the
industry tangible so the you know one
day a week that you don't have animal
products you start to actually realize
and put into real terms and
conceptualize what that means you know
for more than just you right yeah no I
think yeah I think that's what I was
trying to say earlier about Americans is
that we're not always conscious
consumers and that's I feel like the the
coolest part about being a vegan is that
before you buy something you like have a
little bit of a conscience about what
you're buying whereas before when I was
not a vegan and just by what the [ __ ]
ever
I don't care where it came from or you
know what it is barley you're hungry for
just I'm just gonna buy it and eat it
yeah and it just gave me a better
perspective to be like oh I would like
to know some information before I buy
this you know I'm sure so even if one
day a week you let me feed you I think
it would be fun I love that guys chime
in you know like give us your thoughts
on you know if you have a situation are
you have questions or you have you know
thoughts about what we said in terms of
how diets work is you know specific to
us yeah or what your situation is in
terms of your significant other or your
family like what are your different
diets and what are your challenges
because I'm genuinely interested how
other people coexist also make sure to
chime in about the movie theater debate
because I think that's a good thing I'll
talk about I love the community you guys
have that like up on the vlogs on the
podcast anytime you know it's very rare
that it gets to be hostile and I like
that I like that you guys can have
discussions because that's what the
comment section or did you ever keep
kosher when you were a kid no I was
never religious like that yeah never I
used to work at a Jewish dad not too bad
once oh it's very good
it's [ __ ] really good hey I mean
challah bread no matzah bride is what's
a bride like the eggs of bread no matzah
bride it's in there
it's when you like make eggs with I
don't
I'm glad about it uh I'm sorry a Jewish
day camp I had a lot of Jewish friends
and so at the day camp we would always
keep kosher yeah it's like pretty
awesome I mean I'm down I just have
never done it no I can't keep kosher
because I don't eat meat or dairy you
just drink water true
Gatorade is that kosher true Gator in
water I can't remember do you read
I feel like in water I asked you this
the other day and asked ABS this the
explanation of keeping kosher I can't
remember a hundred percent but it's like
really beautiful something about like
you wouldn't consume the mother and the
baby at the same time if you were eating
like a cow or a chicken I'm sure someone
will correct
it's really beautiful though that you
wouldn't eat the mother in the OB so you
wouldn't drink its milk and I don't
[ __ ] know but it was really wonderful
yeah but that's not talking about that's
like you might be American but if you
were Jewish and that was your religion
you have some sort you have some sort of
conscience about what you're consuming I
feel like I was raised with no
conscience so it's nice to have a
conscience yeah for sure
and you guys are cool and I want to know
what you say you guys are cool in your
conscience you're cool
and you can stay cool all through the
night with some ball and bran sheets I
go to Boleyn branch calm right now enter
Jenna Julianne at checkout for 20% off
your new order of wonderfully luxurious
but wonderfully affordable sheets that's
bull and branch calm also me undies guys
win-win Valentine's Day this year but a
meet a nice calm pick out one of the
under underwear you know from the
amazing selection of their underwears
and and make your partner your friend
your pet really really happy a new pair
of me undies mate got bought half a
fantastic me undies makes debat happy
that has been proven go to me undies
calm slash Jenna Julian 20% off you also
get free shipping and if you're in the
u.s. ordered before February 4th to get
your order by Wednesday thank you to
responsible thank you thank you to you
wonderful people for sitting around and
listening to us jabber on
about the movies about the movies enough
about the movies Thank You Lauren
anyways um that's cool though
what are we speaking of which though
what are we gonna eat for dinner tonight
remember
Julian's always so hungry I'm trying to
have more protein shake so I'm really
trying to be good because we're trying
to eat more protein another one via
protein shakes
you know like it's good for me I was
flattered anyway we're gonna go up have
another one dinner
Wow see you guys next week talk to you
guys next week thanks for hanging out
have a great wonderful productive happy
yeah bye friends